All right, let's speak next to Ivan from California,
Ivan from California, you're on the air.
David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Oh, excellent.
Oh, well, David Pakman.
Mm hmm.
OK, so, yeah, something I've been thinking
about lately is to what point could we call
the Republican Party fascist or like crypto
fascist or is that even productive?
Oh, I think it's not.
I think I think I've been using more the term
here's the way I've been seeing it, because
sometimes when you when you over label, you
just damage yourself.
Trump is authoritarian and he has fascistic
tendencies.
And I think he would love to be a dictator
if he could get away with it.
But saying this is a fascist administration,
Trump's desires are fascistic.
I don't know that we get that much from saying
this is fascism.
And I think it's sort of discounts real fascism
that we've seen in practice.
I think Trump has fascistic delusions.
I see, I see.
OK, thank you.
Can I ask you a little quickie?
Sure, yeah, go ahead.
So I'm sure you're familiar with Corky Lewis,
but of course and of course, any other great
Argentine writers should look into.
Yeah.
You know, actually, let me let's see one.
I don't know if you've read or remember which
one.
The witch, which.
OK, so so certainly Julio Cortazar is fantastic.
And he wrote the novel Rahula, which is hopscotch
translated in English and a bunch of short
stories that are really good.
I would dig into some of that.
Lovely.
So much peace and love.
All right.
Peace and love, peace and love.
Thank you so much.
Great to hear from you.
A lot of references.
A lot a lot of memetic references in that
call for sure.
Let's go next to, uh, where did we want to
go?
A lot of people just listening, which is totally
fine.
I'm not going to force you in.
Let's go to, um.
Let's go to Roland from Vienna.
Roland from Vienna.
David, hello, how are you?
David, great, great, great lesson.
Congrats on the Georgia runoff.
Yes.
I'm I'm a 40 year old white male from the
middle of Europe.
OK, is it weird to say that Stacey Abrams
is my new hero?
No, no.
I mean, what she's been able to do is is incredible.
It's you know, earlier we had that call about
Democrats failing on organizing.
Stacey Abrams, Stacey Abrams should be explaining
to national Democrats how to organize, quite
frankly.
Yeah, that's in fact, the only downside I'm
seeing is a.
It's all good for Chuck Schumer to be in the
driving seat now, but why did Nancy Pelosi
have to stay there?
All right, well, listen, I mean, I think the
truth is that.
What really matters is sort of like the average
placement on the political spectrum of the
House and Senate and the Senate has been pulled
a little to the left with the addition of
Asaph and Warnock and or significantly to
the left and the House.
Even though Democrats lost seats, some of
the people who won are more left.
So I think I think it's OK.
I think there's a realistic chance to get
some important things done here.
Or you'll get there, you'll get there.
Listen, thanks a lot for what you're doing.
To be honest, I started watching you about
a year ago.
Yes.
And I started watching for the political commentary
and then I kept watching for the comedy.
It is especially your live streams.
It's hilarious.
So much fun with the callers also.
And I think it's time for a spin off show.
Really.
And what would your spinoff be like?
You're seeing a comedy show.
Yeah, yeah, you have to yeah, maybe some viewer
generated content, I know you have, and I'm
also a big fan of your your one of your regular
callings to the voicemail, the Egemen.
Yes, of course.
Egemen is a fantastic caller.
That'll roll.
And I like that idea.
We'll take that under advisement.
Maybe a scripted comedy.
My middle name, my middle name is expert.
So it's going to be expert in the Eckmann.
I'm going to connect with that guy and we'll
make it happen for you, David.
Let's do it.
All right.
Yes.
Eggman and expert, let's put everybody together.
Have a good one.
OK, thanks.
There's a Roeland from Vienna very, very excited
to do a collab with the Egemen.